- Wall Street realized they
could go from being the bad guys
after the '08 crisis
to being the good guys
if they just said
the right things,
muse about diversity
and inclusion,
unjust impact of climate change
after you fly in a
private jet to Davos,
it's pretty good work
if you can get it.
It was a cynical
arranged marriage though,
between two partners
in that marriage
that did not particularly
love or respect one another,
big business and the
Neo-progressive woke movement.
But together, they were each
able to get something out
of the trade.
It was more like
mutual prostitution.
And that was what led to
the birth of Woke Inc.
It wasn't just woke, and
it wasn't just the Inc,
it was both of 'em.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the co-founder
of Strive Asset Management
as well as the author
of the brand new book,
Nation of Victims,
Identity Politics,
The Death of Merit, and the
Path Back to Excellence,
Vivek Ramaswamy.
Welcome, finally,
to the Ruben Report.
- It's good to talk to
you, man. How are you?
- I am doing well.
I have wanted to have you
on for quite some time.
And then about, I don't know,
it was about four
or five months ago,
I was hosting a PragerU event
in West Palm and you were
one of the keynote speakers
and you actually blew me away.
You're a phenomenal
public speaker,
great way of connecting
with the audience,
talking about all the things
that I'm always
yammering on about.
So that's what I wanna dive
into on the show today.
But before we get into business
and why you're doing
this and the book,
give me a little Vivek 101,
little backstory of little Vivek
and what got him to
be this power player
in business and culture.
- Yeah, I don't know.
I can't, you know,
promise all the answers,
but I can tell you a
little bit about my story.
You know, I grew up
at Cincinnati, Ohio.
My parents were
immigrants from India.
My dad came over in
the late seventies,
my mom in the early eighties.
And, you know, we
would frequently joke
around about why on earth you
came halfway around the world
to southwest Ohio.
And my dad's reason for coming
was that his older sister was
in Fort Wayne, Indiana,
which of course begged the
question of why she came halfway
around the world to
Fort Wayne, Indiana.
And our family joke is that
it is the only US state
with the word "India" contained
in the name of the state.
So that gives you a sense
of what the upbringing was,
corny jokes in the Midwest.
And that was, you know,
the immigrant upbringing
which I could, you know,
tell you all about.
Some of that's in
the book actually,
but anyway, I ended up
going into science first.
I went to Harvard studying
molecular biology,
thought I was gonna
be a scientist,
ended up in the world
of biotech investing,
which I did for seven
years, from 2007 to 2014.
About three years in I
had this itch to study law
and political philosophy.
I had been such a
science centric guy
that I told my bosses
that I was gonna leave
my hedge fund job
and go to law school.
I had a seat at Yale.
They said, keep your job,
keep managing a
portfolio if you want.
I said that sounds great.
So I did that for three
years, from 2010 to 2013.
When I graduated,
I no longer had law
school on my docket.
So I used the extra time
for an ignominious short lived
stint as a standup comedian
in New York city.
That did not work out
well. It was humbling.
And ultimately-
- (laughs) Wait. What year?
What year was that?
- That was 2013 and early 2014.
So 2013 was when
I did my 10 shows.
- I wonder man if we
crossed paths at that time,
that was like right around
when I was in the thick of it
over there.
- And do you remember
- Were you in comedy as well?
what clubs you were doing?
Oh, yeah. I used
to be funny man.
Long time ago.
- Okay, so I did like
Broadway Comedy Club, Gotham.
- Yeah?
- A couple other places, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, woo.
- That's pretty funny.
- 10 shows
and then you're retired, huh?
- Yeah, and then
I hung the jersey
on that due to the better advice
of friends and family
(laughs) who were, you know,
very honest audience members.
But anyway, then I,
yeah, it's a long story,
but it led me to the doorstep
of founding my company,
which was a biotech
company that, you know,
all the things that I saw
from my career as an investor
that frustrated me as an
outside investor in biotech,
I wanted to fix.
Decided to do it by
starting a company.
And so built the company, led
it as CEO from 2014 to 2021,
we developed a
number of medicines.
Some of them failed.
Some of them worked.
Five of them are FDA
proof products today,
which I'm incredibly proud of.
But at the end of the day,
I ended up having
to step down in 2021
to focus on what I
saw as a new cancer,
a cultural cancer that
threatened the very dream
that allowed me to
achieve everything I
ever had in my life.
And, you know, look, I was
worried about this new trend,
about the merger of corporate
power and state power
to advance political agendas
through the private sector.
I had some of those
firsthand experiences myself
in my experience as a CEO
of a multi-billion
dollar biotech company.
There were some demands
that came with it that I,
you know, that I thought were
threatening to the system
of American capitalism
and democracy.
And so that led me to step
aside to write my first book,
which was Woke Inc,
which I think you
might be familiar with.
I published that book enjoyed
for a year and a half
traveling the country.
No agenda, just
speaking my mind freely
without any corporate agenda,
any political agenda,
really enjoyed that,
that led to my
second book as well,
which was a sequel to Woke Inc.
That's the one that
we're talking about now.
But I decided that I wasn't
gonna just change the world
by writing books.
I needed to do something
about the problems
I was describing,
and that's what led me also
more recently to found Strive,
which is our new firm competing
directly against BlackRock.
So, that's sort
- That's it.
of the life career
journey in a nutshell.
- All right, you gave me a
lot of avenues to go down.
So let's back up for a second
'cause obviously I
wanna talk about Strive
and I wanna talk
about the new book.
But Woke Inc., I mean,
basically, you know,
you were laying out
that this woke thing
that we were all seeing,
it's going going through
the universities,
it's on television everywhere,
you turn on Apple TV,
that it's not just sort of
this organic thing coming
from kids off Tumblr,
that there actually
is an organizational
ideology behind it.
So can you talk about
that a little bit?
'cause people always ask
me either when I do QnA's
on the show where
I go out publicly.
Where is it coming from?
What is driving it truly?
- Yeah, so I mean, look,
that took a whole separate
book length work to describe,
but one of the things I said
in that book was that it
when wokeness met capitalism,
that it actually
became unstoppable.
And it was supercharged
with the dollars that flow
through our system of free
market American capitalism.
That's when it really
became not just a challenge
to the system, it
became the system.
And it happened in the aftermath
of the 2008 financial crisis.
And I saw this firsthand, right.
I, you know, got my first
job at that hedge fund
in New York city
in the fall of 2007
on the eve of the '08 crisis.
And the long story short,
and it is a long story,
and it was, you know,
it was my last book.
So we could go on for
hours about this one.
But the short version
of it is that Wall Street
realized they could go
from being the bad guys
after the '08 crisis
to being the good guys if they
just said the right things,
muse about diversity
and inclusion,
unjust impact of climate change
after you fly in a
private jet to Davos.
It's pretty good work
if you can get it.
It was a cynical
arranged marriage though,
between two partners
in that marriage
that did not particularly
love or respect one another,
big business and the
Neo-progressive woke movement.
But together, they were each
able to get something out
of the trade.
It was more like
mutual prostitution.
And that was what led to
the birth of Woke Inc.
It wasn't just woke and
it wasn't just the Inc,
it was both of them.
And that's what that
whole tale was about.
I will tell you
that over the course
of writing that book though,
I was interested in both the
corporate cynicism behind it,
which is what that book
ended up being about.
But I was also
interested in the content
of the underlying
ideology as well.
And so the publisher
kind of told me
and advisors who helped
me put that book together
and said, look, you gotta
pick one or the other.
Start with the first one.
And then actually the
unfinished work was what led
to Nation of Victims,
which is the book that
I'm putting out now.
So, you know, that was
a bit of the journey
of the two books.
The first one was really about
the corporate financial fuel
and the second book is really
about the underlying flyer,
the fire, the configuration
on which corporations threw
that fuel.
And together, I think
they describe the problem.
- I assume that the
irony should not be lost
on anyone that as
you describe it,
it was capitalism that allowed
this thing to be unleashed,
which is virulently
anti-capitalist.
- Of course.
And you know?
Ludwig von Mises, a famous
economist, you know, Schumpeter,
Joseph Schumpeter
himself, you know,
said very similar things.
This is early 20th century
stuff from von Mises
that capitalism creates a
psychological need filled
by anti-capitalism, you know.
Schumpeter kind of
predicted the same thing,
the system of
creative destruction.
But first capitalism gives rise,
necessarily paves
the way to socialism.
That was kind of
Schumpeter thesis.
And it's interesting.
You know, we see
their predictions
play out in the moment
that you and I live in.
I mean, you're
technically a millennial.
You're a millennial as well?
- I believe I'm 46, my friend.
I am Gen X.
- You're on the other side
of the bridge.
- I am Gen X.
- Okay.
- You look good, man.
- So, I don't know,
but I'm a millennial.
So I'm what, 37 now.
So my generation, I was
gonna say our generation,
but we'll call it my generation.
- I have a lot of
younger friends.
- That's good, you know,
whatever you get it.
It's a spectrum anyway,
Your generation sort of,
the younger part of your
generation counts in this.
But the millennials
in particular,
we're on the receiving end.
I mean, I'm personally not
on the receiving end of this,
but millennials as a generation
are on the receiving end
of the largest intergenerational
wealth transfer
in human history.
And there's something
about that that creates
this psychological need
for self-criticism and
criticism of the very system
that created the wealth that
you're otherwise gonna be
on the receiving end of,
but without actually
making the sacrifice
of giving up that inheritance,
to be able to apologize for it
with this new self
found consciousness
of your privilege or whatever
it is that lies at the heart
of the apologism
that characterizes.
And I don't even use
the word woke anymore,
'cause it's sort of
become a tired word,
but the modern
Neo-progressive movement,
the apologist culture,
that's really at the
heart of my next book.
Which is the victimhood culture
that permeates our
American fabric today.
- Are you surprised
that it rampaged
through so many businesses?
I mean, businesses
that were were
or should be based
on actual numbers.
It's one thing, okay.
It rampages through an
entertainment company,
you know, somebody making
movies, TV shows, et cetera,
but like seemingly everything,
accounting firms and banks,
like the whole freaking
thing, that, you know,
these are people that actually
have to look at numbers
and make sense based on reality
or at least are supposed to.
- Yeah, you know, at
first it's surprising,
of course it's
counterintuitive, right?
That's why it made for
an interesting book.
But when you examine it,
it's actually not
surprising at all
because it serves the interests
of many of the people who
are the biggest propagators
of this new ideology.
I mean, look, Larry Fink
at BlackRock used this
as a philosophy to
aggregate over $10 trillion,
creating the world
assets under management.
That's something that
he couldn't have done
if it weren't fulfilling
the void created
by the 2008 financial
crisis and telling people
that this was actually
the new capitalism itself.
And so, you know, I
think the people on top,
by the way without
saying an iota
about those same words in China.
How do you know it's
in their self-interest?
You talk about ESG or DEI or CSR
or whatever your three favorite
three letter acronym is,
when they go over to the
other three letter acronym
from ESG, DEI and CSR to CCP,
to be able to do business in
China without saying a peak
about ESG or DEI, because
that's what it pays
to do over there.
Now in the United States,
it paid to do it because
pension funds like California,
CalPERS, you know, state
of New York, they said,
we're only gonna do
business with firms
that adopt these
progressive commitments.
Well, they said, you know what?
Those are where the biggest
checks are coming from.
That's the tune
we're gonna dance to.
And so in a certain sense,
when the economic incentives
were set up that way,
it wasn't altogether surprising
that people responded
to those incentives.
I think, you know, my new
book is Nation of Victims.
We sort of talk about that at
the individual level as well.
Why is victimhood culture so
rampant in the United States?
It's a bit of a
curiosity, right?
You know, we have living in
the most prosperous moments
in human history and
in American history,
why is it then that we
fashion ourselves to think
of ourselves as victims
in every given direction?
Black victims, white victims,
second generation Asian victims.
I mean, it's everywhere.
We in certain senses create
an incentive structure
in our country that
rewards someone
for characterizing
themselves as a victim
rather than as a victor.
And so I think that, you know,
it's not a sort of a
cheesy humans respond
to incentives kind of
argument all the way down,
but that is an important
part of the story.
And it's certainly
a part of the story
that makes it less surprising
than you'd otherwise think.
- So I wanna get to some of
that psychology behind that.
Real quick, just to back up.
I think most of my audience
is following you on BlackRock
and ESG and some
of the other stuff,
but for some of the
people that are missing,
maybe some of the pieces here.
First off, can you explain sort
of what BlackRock is and how
that is connected to ESG?
We've talked a bit
about ESG on the show,
but I think if we kind of
lay it out somewhat simply,
I think that'll
help some people.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So look, you know,
the ESG movement,
people hear this acronym.
I mean, what is it, okay?
So it stands
for Environmental, Social
and Governance factors.
And it basically
is a close cousin
of a broader movement called
stakeholder capitalism,
which refers to the idea
that businesses should not
just sell products and
services for profit,
but they should also advance
other societal agendas
and other social
interests, okay.
That's the philosophy.
Agree or not,
that's what it says.
Now, what that's become is a
vehicle for government actors
to effectuate through
the private sector
what they could not effectuate
through the front door
of policy making.
So one example let's take
is the climate agenda,
the Green New Deal, whatever
you may want to call it.
The Green New Deal did not
muster political support
to be passed through Congress.
Well, what the ESG movement
offered was a vehicle
to lean on many companies
to sign what you call a
climate pledge instead,
get every company to
voluntarily, "voluntarily",
by the way.
(Dave laughs)
I use that in air
quotes because it's
with the invisible fist
of government behind it,
but to voluntarily
adopt net zero standards
and pledges by 2050,
unilateral pledges to support
the Paris Climate Accords
and abide by its demands,
even though the US
did not ratify the
Paris Climate Accords,
the Paris Climate Agreement.
The private sector effectively
ratifies it instead.
I actually, this an aside,
I sent a public letter
as a shareholder
to the board of Chevron
earlier this week complaining
amongst other things
about a corporate behavior
about Chevron embracing the
Paris Climate Agreement,
reminding them that the
US did not ratify this.
It is not Chevron's job
to use shareholder capital
to ratify it instead,
especially when it's not
even in the best interests
of that business.
So anyway, that's a
bit about what this is.
You know, let's just say even
the Silicon Valley censorship.
I actually view that as a
subset of this broader problem
of stakeholder capitalism
and the ESG movement.
People think about that
as a separate issue.
I've written extensively about,
you know, about that issue,
about how private actors
actually ought to be bound
by the First Amendment
if they're responding
to government threats.
I, you know, was
talking about that
before that was cool.
- Yeah.
- Back when it was ridiculed
as an idea about a year and ago.
- It's sort of like when
Jen Saki is admitting
that the government flags posts
about disinformation
for Facebook in essence.
- Absolutely, and then
threatens companies
if they don't take
down the post,
that they're gonna be broken up,
that they're gonna
bring antitrust action,
then companies do
it, but they say,
hey, it's not the
government doing it.
It's just the free market.
And the First Amendment doesn't
apply to the free market.
It's another example
of government actors
using private companies
to do through the back door
the dirty work of government
that it could not accomplish
through the front door
under the constitution or
with political accountability.
So that's what this movement
effectively represents.
Now, it, you know, sort of in
a takes two to tango spirit.
It only works if the consumers
and individual investors,
et cetera, in the economy
still fall for it.
At the end of the day,
if consumers would
still resist this
and not buy those products
or individual investors
who exercise their voice
not gonna stand by this
behavior, you know,
this couldn't have existed,
but I think some of that relates
to a moment of
cultural weakness.
And so I think there's
not one story here,
but two storylines that
are really important.
One is the top down
problem, where, you know,
actors like BlackRock,
the world's largest
asset manager.
You asked who they are,
they're the world's largest
asset manager managing
over $10 trillion of
everyday citizens money.
What they do is they
manage that money
by investing in
American companies,
but then to show up in the
boardrooms of those companies
and say that, you know what,
we're not gonna promote you
or we're not gonna pay you,
or we're gonna vote
your directors off
unless you adopt these
environmental social agendas
that we demand.
But they're using the money
of everyday citizens to do it.
Most of those everyday
citizens actually disagree
with that agenda.
So that's the top down problem.
It's a big breach of fiduciary
duty using $10 trillion
of someone else's money to
advance political agendas
that the everyday citizen,
the owner of capital,
disagrees with.
That's the top down problem.
But the bottom up problem
is we have a culture
that's also falling for it and
saying that, you know what?
We actually do demand that
companies behave in ways
that align with our
Neo-progressive values.
And then that gives those
boardrooms cover to be able
to say, well, this is what
consumers are demanding,
and that's what allows Nike
or Disney to behave in the way
that it does.
So it's complicated.
And so the first book
was basically Woke Inc.,
was about the top down problem.
The problem of the
woke capitalist,
the use and abuse,
the use, I should say,
the abuse of capital to be able
to effectuate these political
agendas through the back door
that government
couldn't effectuate
through the front door
and that cynical
arranged marriage.
But the second half of
it is this other problem.
The generational
cultural problem.
The victimhood cancer,
that's the heart of
Nation of Victims,
the next book that explains
this cultural deficit
that allows companies
and government actors
to cynically prey on our
cultural insecurities
as a generation.
And I think that's equally an
important part of the story.
- Okay, so we'll get
to that in a sec,
'cause I think that sort
of the spiritual part
of this that I think many
people are missing right now.
They keep thinking the answer
to this problem is some sort
of government answer
and it's like, no,
that's kind of how we got here.
But just to jump
back for a second.
You mentioned the
fiduciary responsibility
that these boards have
to their shareholders.
Are you surprised or was
there an example of a company
where the shareholders were
able to fight this effectively?
I mean, I remember
literally on my show five
or six years ago when Google
AdSense was clamping down
on everybody.
I had a couple guests in a row
and I was calling for it too.
It's like, where are the
shareholders who are going,
well, wait a minute, put
censorship aside for a second.
If they are not putting
ads on certain things,
am I being hurt
as a shareholder?
Like, are there any examples
where the shareholders
actually accomplished anything
or lawsuits or anything?
- Not a ton yet. That's what
I'm working on, man. (laughs)
- (laughs) Right. All right.
- I started Strive.
So Strive is a new firm
competing with BlackRock.
We just sent a public letter
to Chevron calling out a lot
of these behaviors
that, crucially though,
were forced on them by
BlackRock, State Street,
and Vanguard.
In many cases, Chevron
actually said initially
that they opposed
these proposals,
but then the large shareholders
vote for them anyway.
And this is the problem, Drew,
a lot of the movement,
you know, that, you know,
you would advocate for
shareholder-centric power.
What they miss is that
the 21st century version
of this problem is different
and they've thrown a trip wire
that a lot of us fell for,
which was that they said,
okay, Milton Friedman,
you said that
shareholders rule, right?
And company management teams
report to shareholders.
Well, guess what?
We are the shareholder.
And we are demanding
that you the company management
adopt these social agendas.
You're not betraying your
fiduciary duty to us.
You're actually working for us
'cause we're the shareholder.
Milton Friedman all
along said it, rule,
and you owe the duty to us
and we the shareholder
are demanding it.
So here's the fallacy
in that argument.
But that's effectively what
allowed this problem to spread
like wildfire is the
parlance of fiduciary duty
to shareholder misses the
fact that the shareholder,
I use shareholder air quotes,
is actually the one
pushing the agenda.
So to do this, we have
to get a little academic
for a second.
- Let's roll. Let's roll.
I got a bright audience.
- It'll be all right.
- If you don't follow this,
I'll stop, but okay.
So the whole shareholder
privacy doctrine came from,
it was a vestige of 20th
century corporate law
and even Friedman, I thinking
in the late 20th century,
that solved a problem called
the separation of ownership
and control, okay.
So the CEO has
control of the firm,
but the shareholder
owns the firm.
They're not the same person,
that gives rise to what's called
a principle agent conflict.
The shareholders, the
principle, the CEOs,
the agent leads to the
private jet problem
of, you know, CEOs that
are flying on private jets
using the shareholder
capital to do it.
You know, that RJR Nabisco
problem, over spending.
Well, how do you close that gap?
It's by imposing
a fiduciary duty
on the CEO to the shareholder.
So Milton Friedman said the CEO
can't pursue these
social agendas
without serving the
interest of the shareholder.
That's where the
fiduciary duty came from.
That's the 20th century stuff.
It's called the separation
of ownership and control.
The 21st century version of
this problem is different.
It is not the separation
of ownership and control.
It is the separation of
ownership and ownership.
And what I mean by that is
the parties who now then claim
to be the owners, the
shareholders of these companies
like BlackRock, State
Street, and Vanguard,
they are not the actual
owners of those companies
because they launched these
so-called passive index funds
that aggregated trillions of
dollars in the last 15 years
that are the money
of everyday citizens
who are the actual
owners of the company,
but invested via vehicles
that were managed
by a managerial clique that
then showed up in the boardrooms
of those companies and
said, you know what?
I am the shareholder and I'm
demanding you behave this way.
But the class-
- So basically in
essence though,
the average shareholder
probably didn't even know
what was going on.
- They didn't know
what's going on.
They didn't know
So the way I talk about this
is no longer as shareholders,
but as the owners
of the company,
the actual end owner of
capital, the everyday citizen,
whose money is being invested
through a plinko chips
mediated financial system
that then goes into
a pension fund,
that then asks an investment
consultant where to invest,
that then invests in a
fund managed by BlackRock,
that then invests in a company.
It's such an
intermediated system,
but the actual owner
of capital has no idea
that that state pension
fund and its board member
and its investment staff
and BlackRock were
betraying their interests
by representing viewpoints
in corporate
America's boardrooms,
in the boardrooms of
companies like Chevron,
the one I wrote to
earlier this week,
in ways that the owner
of capital had no idea
was actually happening.
So that's really how
this plays out in reality
where the parties who claim
to be the shareholders
are not the actual shareholders
and that's the big problem.
- Okay, so with that in mind,
let's shift a little bit to
the sort of spiritual part
of this or the generational,
the cultural part that
you're talking about.
You mentioned before
from Indian background,
you grew up in the Midwest.
I mean, I suspect that
whether it was your parents
or great grandparents or
whatever it might be that came
from India, I'm guessing
they didn't come with a lot
and they probably had to work.
- They didn't come with a
lot. Nope, they did not.
- And I'm guessing that
they don't feel very guilty
about your success.
- No, they don't,
and that's the thing.
Whether they're
Republican, Democrat,
the thing you find
about immigrants who
come to this country
through the front door,
and I distinguish that,
you know, for coming
through the back.
Legal immigrants
by and large come
to this country to
pursue excellence,
to pursue their dreams,
to pursue excellence,
without having to
apologize for it.
Leaving places that
were anti-meritocratic
to come to a meritocratic
nation where regardless
of your creed or skin color,
you can achieve anything you
want with your own hard work
and commitment and dedication.
That used to be our
national identity.
We now have a new
national identity built
on victimhood instead.
And one of the things, you know,
my parents taught me,
say from a young age,
is that hardship is
not the same thing
as you're gonna encounter
hardship in your life.
It's part of what
teaches you who you are.
But we live now in a moment
where we kids are taught,
the next generation,
by the way, you know,
I was first generation, my
parents were the immigrants.
I was born in America.
The second and third generation,
even in the Asian
American communities,
are being taught this new
narrative to say that,
you know what?
The more you think of
yourself as a victim,
as a person of color,
or whatever your
victim narrative is,
that's how you
get ahead in life,
not by actually unapologetically
embracing the pursuit
of excellence.
And that's become our
new national identity.
A national idea that was
built on the shared pursuit
of excellence has
since perverted
into this new national identity
that that's taken the form
of this victimhood
grievance Olympics
where there is no gold medalist.
It is our nation and
our national identity
that loses in the end.
And that's the heart of this
whole new book, you know.
That's why I wrote the
book is someone who needed
to expose this in some ways
as a first generation American
looking at this, not as
somebody who inherited America,
but whose parents came to
this country voluntarily
with their two feet to be part
of that national identity.
And yet now, 40 years later,
found a new national
identity centered
on this black hole of
victimhood instead.
- Did the Neo-libs or the
libs or the Neo-progressives
or whatever version,
whatever language you
wanna use around that,
is there some reason that they
inherently failed with this?
You know, that they
didn't defend the ideas
that their ancestors came
here for well enough?
- Yes, so I think some
of it was this
generational insecurity.
I think it's this idea
that when you haven't
encountered hardship, actually,
you begin to hunger
for it. (chuckles)
You know, there's something
about the human psyche.
It's a funny thing.
We require hardship and the
experience of overcoming it
to remind ourselves the contours
of our soul, of who we are.
I gave the high school
commencement address
to my own high school
where I graduated.
I gave commencement address
when, I graduated what, in 2003.
They invited me back to give
an updated address last year
at last year's commencement.
And it struck me,
that was the first
graduating class
that had in-person graduation
were not a single member
of that class was
even born on the day
that those twin towers were
hit by those two planes.
And that defined part of
my high school experience.
I mean, I was in high school,
I was in AP history
class or US history class
at that particular time.
It was, you know, it
was a defining moment.
This is you're looking
at a generation
where not a single person had
been through that experience.
And I'm not saying
that it had to be 9/11,
but, you know, I think a
generation that actually
is on the receiving end
of that intergenerational
wealth transfer
that hasn't had to necessarily
as either as a citizen
or as an individual fight for
the kind of right to be able
to be proud, needs to then
see themselves as the victim
of some other hardship instead.
And so you could argue, maybe
it's not even their fault.
This is just what the arc
of history has dealt our
generation, millennials, Gen Z,
and younger, to have
to think of themselves
as encountering hardships that
don't even actually exist,
and then reinvent that
victimhood narrative
until a new one
is dealt in its place instead.
But the problem is, if you live
in that victimhood narrative
for long enough, you're not
even gonna have the fortitude
to fight that hardship
when it actually comes.
Maybe that's China, maybe
it's something else.
Whatever it is, if we don't
turn this culture around,
I think we will have actually
lost the very fortitude
that we might have gotten
from actually encountering
more part of the
diagnosis for me.
- Yeah, it's interesting
you're making a distinction
that I try to bring
up all the time
that it's perceived oppression,
not necessarily even
real oppression.
- That's right.
- It's something that's
made up in their mind.
So where do you think
big tech fits in this?
You know, when we hear
things like, well, okay,
all of this gender stuff
and all of this woke stuff,
it's pushed on all of kids
in America through TikTok,
but it's banned in China.
Do you think that there
might be a connection there?
- Yeah, or even the parent
company that owns TikTok
in China actually uses it
to like educate kids on math
and science and reading,
which is different than the way
we're educating people here.
So look, I mean,
mostly when I'm talking
about, you know,
big tech or the term big tech,
I'm usually talking about
the censorship debate,
which, you know,
I have views on.
But that's not what I'm
gonna talk about here.
This is a different issue
and I think it's an
important one where,
look, one of the
things I often say,
not to get too
philosophical here,
but will just for a second,
is that virtue is not a
product of capitalism, okay.
Virtue is a pre-condition for
capitalism to do its work.
And what I mean by
that is that, look,
a similar way of saying
that is capitalism
would be the perfect system
for organizing a
society's affairs
if our wants actually
matched our needs.
And to the extent that
there's anything wrong
with negative externalities
with capitalism,
it can be explained, entirely,
I believe by the daylight
between our wants and needs.
And I think part of what the
stakeholder capitalism movement
gets wrong is that it demands
of these capitalist actors
the need to cultivate virtue
that should have been
cultivated through institutions
that predate capitalism
or capital in the society.
- The family, church.
- Families, perhaps? Right.
- Yeah, religion,
whatever it is, you know.
Where you pray,
national identity,
patriotism's at the level
of the community, at the level
of the family, absolutely.
So where do we see this
play out as it relates
to tech companies and
where does the debate
even get confused even by
conservatives over the last year
for example, was when I saw the
story breakout by, you know,
the Wall Street Journal doing
reporting that, you know,
Facebook knew that
the young teen girls
who were using Instagram had
body image insecurity issues
that were fueled and
made worse by Instagram,
and they didn't do
anything about it.
And by the way,
they knew that they were
making anger management issues
amongst their angry
users even worse,
but didn't do anything about it.
And so, you know, conservative
media called me to talk
about that issue 'cause
I had been a long critic
of censorship by big
tech and said, okay,
let's hit 'em hard.
They knew and they didn't
do anything about it.
And actually my view was
actually, no, no, no,
you're getting this
all wrong, actually.
We should not as a society
want Mark Zuckerberg
or Jack Dorsey to be our
priests and rabbis to virtue.
In fact, we should want a
society that cultivates the kind
of self-confidence
among young teen girls
that don't leave them
vulnerable to the insecurities
that these algorithms
are designed to prey on.
And I think that
we miss the fact
that we can cultivate that
sense of psychic fortitude
and virtue in the offline world
so that these professionally
created algorithms
aren't so well equipped to pick
at and prey on those
insecurities by
knowing what you click
on versus what you
don't click on and use
that to create a window to
your soul that sees your soul
with greater clarity
than you see yourself.
That's just the antecedent
condition of the divergence
of your want and need,
that deficit of virtue that
allowed the modern, demonic,
algorithm empowered version
of modern capitalism
and technology, the
industry part of it,
to prey on those insecurities.
It's kind of like the
equivalent of a teen girl
in the 1990s, you know,
of Virginia Slims manufacturers
selling cigarettes
to that teen girl who had
body imaging security issues
back then.
It's the same thing
all over again
when the thing we
need to be addressing
is the generational
insecurity in the first place
and cultivating that
psychic fortitude
that actually allows
capitalism to then do its work,
to sell us the goods
and services we want
more effectively
when we already have a
deep seated self-confidence
and understanding of
who we are as people
that predate our
identity as capitalists.
And so this is one of
the solutions I talk
about in the book is, you
know, one of the places
I wanna see the conservative
movement do better
is to provide an affirmative
answer to those questions
about identity, about
national identity,
about individual identity,
and to talk not just
about the revival
of freedom through system
or system of free
market capitalism
where I'm one of the
greatest champions
for exactly that model,
but also to talk about
a revival of let's say,
civic identity, our
identity as citizens,
and the psychic fortitude
that we require as citizens.
And the civic duty that comes
in our capacity as a citizen
from our identity as just a
capitalist who's participant
in that economy.
And so what did big tech
do? They called that bluff.
Modern social media called
the bluff of a generation
that didn't know what
they actually wanted
and then preyed on those
psychic insecurities
to build multi-trillion
dollar companies
that were not tech companies.
They were psychologically
shrewd companies that understood
that they could
understand you better
with their algorithms than
you could understand yourself.
And maybe if you understood
yourself even more effectively,
that might have actually
prevented modern social media
from having the toxic
effects that it's since had.
- Vivek am I a crazy
conspiracy theorist
or is it possible that
for all those years
that Buzzfeed had
everyone clicking
on those nonsensical poles
of what do they like better,
this or that,
that perhaps that had
a little something,
Buzzfeed and many of these
other sites, but Buzzfeed,
which is now
completely collapsed,
was like the prime
purveyor of all
of us clicking all these
things and they would,
as you sort of alluded to there,
ultimately they would know
what we actually want more
than we can even understand.
- That's not a conspiracy.
That's a reality.
I mean, even look
at Mark Zuckerberg.
I mean, his genius was not
his technical aptitude.
The predecessor to Facebook,
I mean, I was at Harvard
with him at the same time.
He was a year ahead of me
back then, was hot or not.
You know, this or this right.
(Dave laughs)
Sort of taking these native
based human instincts
and just picking at them and
exploiting them, you know.
Now does that mean that we
should regulate the companies
and prevent them
from doing that?
No, no, no. You're
getting it all wrong.
We need to revive the very
institutions at the level
of the family, at the
level of the nation,
at the level of the community,
at the level of even our
religious institutions,
to fill that void of meaning
and purpose and identity.
That then prepares
us for a society
where in free market capitalism
we don't need to apologize
for the fact that some guy
ends up with more green pieces
of paper than the other.
Who cares if we fetishize
those green pieces of paper?
The thing that really matters
is that we have civic equality
as citizens.
That we're grounded in the forms
of identity that really matter.
And that's where I wanna see
the conservative movement
do better in stepping up
to fill that void in a way
that it's completely
abdicated any interest
in actually taking on.
That's part of what motivated
me to say that, you know,
I just wasn't done
with just Woke Inc.
You know, Nation of Victims
was about taking a crack.
I'm not saying I
have all the answers,
but taking a crack at what
fills that void of identity.
What does it mean to be an
American in the year 2022?
If we don't have a good
answer to that question,
maybe we as a movement
need to be stepping up
and answer that question or
else you're just gonna have
that same poison continuing
to fill that black hole
of a vacuum of identity,
rather than just
taking a jackhammer
to sort of weed out that
poison one at a time.
Maybe you try a different
strategy of diluting the poison
to irrelevance by filling
it with a new rich vision
for what that identity could
be that dilutes the poison
to irrelevance.
That's the approach I'm
interested in taking.
- So before we
finish with Strive,
which is the culmination
of all of this,
are you enthused or
do you see markers
that some of what you're
calling for is happening?
I mean, as you know,
I toured with Jordan
Peterson for two years.
The level of exactly what
you're asking for there in terms
of personal responsibility,
family, belief,
all of these things.
I mean, he's spreading
that across the world.
I see that coming now out of
other corners of conservatism.
So it's not just, ah, government
off our back and low taxes.
There's actually
something more robust.
I see that kind of happening.
Do you agree with that?
- Yeah, I do.
I do see a potential
shift in the tide.
You know, it's interesting.
One of the things I cover
in Nation of Victims,
the second book is,
is actually I take
a look at history,
not just our national history.
A lot of it goes into the
parts of the civil war history
that I hadn't reminded
myself of since high school,
but even through a
lot of Roman history.
And one of the things I reminded
myself of is we often talk
about the rise and fall of Rome
and then draw the analogies
to the rise and fall of
the American experiment.
And one of the things that
I reminded myself as part
of the research for the
book, and it, you know,
it's in a couple of
the chapters there now
is that there was
no one fall of Rome.
There were many
rises and many falls.
And there were moments
in what you thought might have
been the fall where the idea
of Rome reinvented
itself, right?
Not just the place,
Rome was an idea.
In a certain sense,
America was that idea.
Both were built on this
idea of exceptionalism.
In a certain sense,
you can even...
Not to get waxed too
philosophical about it,
but maybe Rome was reborn.
Maybe Rome was reborn in 1776.
And I think the idea
of unapologetically
leading in the way
that the American
experiments sought to lead,
these are ideas.
Nations don't die the
way that human beings do.
They're constantly
reborn as something else.
I was actually raised
in a Hindu upbringing.
We weaved some Hindu philosophy
into the book about the idea
of individual reincarnation
into the reincarnation
of the idea of a nation,
the reincarnation
of America itself.
You know what?
It's not this
bilateral tug of war
where the tides are changing,
but rather if you look
through the arc of history,
if you look through
the history of Rome,
and then even look at the
history of this this country
that we live in, that
we consider ours,
it has an opportunity to
not just have one rise
and one fall, but to
constantly be reborn,
and to rediscover itself.
And as there were many
rises and falls of Rome,
I predict that there will
be many rises and falls
of this version of Rome,
of America as well.
I'm optimistic that
we're not in...
We're in what feels
like a decline,
but is actually
just the beginning
of a new revival.
And, you know,
I hope we each do our small
part in playing a role
in making that happen.
- There's that positivity
I'm always looking
for on this show.
So now bring us home with Strive
because you don't just talk
about this stuff and just
write books about it.
You actually do
real world stuff.
And my audience is always
trying to figure out real ways
to combat this nonsense.
And I think most of my
audience has done a lot
of the spiritual and
cultural work already.
So they're ready for the,
hey, what's the business
end of this thing?
- Well, I think some of this
can be done through the market.
I never imagined I was gonna
start another business again,
but when I looked at myself
in the mirror and said,
look, how are we gonna
address this problem?
I really saw an
underutilized avenue
to solve this
through the market.
So Strive's a new
investment firm.
We're competing with BlackRock.
We're offering index funds,
just like BlackRock does.
We listed our first index fund
in the New York Stock
Exchange last month.
But the key difference is
we bring a different voice
and vote to the table
where we tell companies
to focus exclusively on
delivering excellent products
and services to their customers
over any other agenda,
social or political agenda.
Actually in Nation of Victims,
the end of the
subtitle of the book
is The Path Back to Excellence.
I think part of the path
back to excellence runs
through the market.
That's actually what Strive
is all about as well.
So just to give you
a tangible example.
The first index fund we listed
is a US energy index fund.
It trades on the New
York Stock Exchange.
Its ticker is DRILL.
And it's a very simple message
to the US energy industry.
You should drill, frack,
do whatever allows you
to be most successful without
having to apologize for it.
If that's what allows
you to be successful
over the long run,
you don't need to advance
somebody else's social
or political agenda.
So that's why we pick,
you know, D-R-I-L-L.
DRILL was to send a
very clear message.
But I also wanna practice
what I'm preaching.
And so, you know,
that fund raised $300 million
in it's first three weeks,
it's first month
or so of trading.
But it's not just
about doing this
for the sake of making a point,
it's to bring a different
shareholder voice to the table.
And I was alluding
to this earlier.
That's why, you know,
even in recent days sent
a letter to the board
of Chevron questioning a lot
of their politicized behaviors
that were influenced by
the likes of BlackRock.
But the problem isn't just
as sit around and complain
about this, well, let's bring
a different shareholder voice
to the table into the boardroom,
and actually go back
to resolving these
through free speech
and open debate, both
in the public square
as citizens on
political questions,
and then back in the boardrooms.
Bring real debate back
into the boardrooms.
Bring actual
diversity of thought,
in the name of diversity
that we've missed
in corporate America, bring
actual diversity of thought
back to the corporate boardroom
to set this culture right
starting with our economy.
So that's what I was doing
with Strive, but, you know,
in some ways it's an embodiment
of what I wrote about not
just in Woke Inc.,
which is the problem,
but even in Nation of Victims
and The Path back to
Excellence, you know,
I think hopefully, you know,
there's no end-all be-all
silver bullet solution,
but I think market solutions
are gonna be an important part
of it and that's where I
chose to focus my attention
in the next chapter.
- Love it, man.
As simple as that.
We will link to the book down
below and I'd keep you longer,
but you're clearly a busy
guy and you got things to do.
It was good to see you, man.
- Good to see you.
Thank you for having me.
We'll see you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.